Seventy years ago I was in high school,
almost a third as long as the country
has been around and when I was in high
school,
I really only had two things on my mind,
girls and cars and and it wasn't doing
very well with girls,
so we'll talk about cars,
but let's just imagine that when we
finished,
I'm going to let each one of you pick
out the car of your choice.
Sounds good,
doesn't it?
Pick it out.
Any color,
you name it,
it will be tied up with a bow and it
will be at your house tomorrow
and you say,
well,
what's the catch?
And the catch is that it's the only car
you're going to get in your lifetime.
Now what are you going to do knowing
that that's the only car you're ever
going to have it and you love that car?
You're going to take care of it by you
cannot believe.
Now,
what I'd like to suggest,
you're not going to get only one car in
your lifetime,
but you only get one body and one mind
and that's all you're going to get and
that body and mind feels terrific now,
but it has to last you a lifetime.
Most important thing is to decide what
is to be able to define which ones you
can come to an intelligent decision on
and which ones are beyond your capacity
to evaluate.
You don't have to be right about
thousands and thousands and thousands of
companies.
You only have to be right about a
company.
A couple.
I met Bill Gates on July fifth,
19,
91.
We were out in Seattle and bill said,
you've got to have a computer.
And I said,
why?
And he said,
well,
he said you can do your income tax on
it.
It said,
I don't have any income.
Berkshire doesn't pay a dividend.
And he said,
well,
you can keep track of your portfolio.
And I said,
I only have one stock.
I said,
I.
He says,
it's going to change everything.
And I said,
well,
will it change whether people chew gum?
And he said,
well,
probably not.
And I said,
well,
we'll change what kind of gum they show.
And I said,
well then I'll stick of chewing gum and
Houston computers.
You
don't have to understand all kinds of
all kinds of businesses I don't
understand,
but there's thousands of opportunities
there.
I did understand the Bank of America,
you know,
and uh,
and I'll be able to,
I'm able to do that.
I'm able to understand some given
percentage.
But Ted Williams wrote a book called the
science of hitting and in science of
hitting,
he's got a diagram,
shows him at the plate and he's got the
strike zone divided into 77 squares each
the size of a baseball.
And he says,
if I only swing at pitches in the sweet
zone,
which he shows there and he has what his
batting average would be,
which is 400.
If he had to swing it low outside
pitches.
But still in the,
in the strike zone is average,
would be 2:30.
He said the most important thing and
hitting is waiting for the right pitch.
Now he was at a disadvantage because of
the account was all in two or one and
two or so on.
Even if that ball was down where he was
only going about 2:30,
he had to swing at it.
In investing,
there's no called strikes.
People Control Microsoft.
That man,
you know your name and any,
any stock,
General Motors,
uh,
and I don't have to swing at nobody's
gonna call me out on called strikes.
I only get a strike called if I swing at
a pitch and mess.
So I can wait there and look at
thousands of companies day after day and
only when I see something I understand
and what I liked the price at which is
selling.
Then if I swing,
if I,
if I headed fine,
if I miss it,
it's,
it's a strike.
But it's an enormously advantageous game
and it's a terrible mistake.
The thing,
you have to have an opinion on
everything.
You only have to have an opinion on a
few things.
In fact,
I've told students if when they got out
of school,
they got a punch card with 20 punches on
it and that's all the investment
decisions they got to make in their
entire life.
They would get very rich because they
would think very hard about each one.
And you don't need 20 right decisions to
get very rich,
you know,
four or five,
we'll probably do it over time.
So,
uh,
I don't worry too much about the things.
I don't understand it.
If you understand some of these
businesses that are coming along and can
spot things on,
if you can spot on Amazon,
for example,
I mean,
it's a tremendous accomplishment what
Jeff Bezos has done,
and I tip my hat to him.
He's a wonderful businessman.
He's a good guy too,
but can I have anticipated that he would
be the success and 10 others wouldn't
be.
I'm not good enough to do that,
but I don't.
Unfortunately,
I don't have to.
You know,
that I don't have to form an opinion on,
on Amazon.
And I do.
I did form an opinion on the Bank of
America and I formed an opinion on Coca
Cola.
Coca Cola has been around since 18,
86.
There's one point 8 billion,
one point 8 billion,
eight ounce servings of Coca Cola
products sold every day.
Now if you take one penny and get one
penny extra,
that's $18,
million dollars a day and 18 million
times 365 is 7 billion.
Seven hundred 30 billion or 6 billion,
$570,000,000.
So annually,
6 million.
Five hundred $70,000,000 from one penny.
Do you think coca cola is worth a penny
more than you know Joe's Cola?
I think so.
So you know,
and I've got about 127 years of history
would indicate it.
So those are the kinds of decisions I
like to make and you may have an
entirely different field of expertise
than I would have probably much more up
to date in terms of the kind of
businesses that seeing above.
And
you can get very rich if you just
understand the few of them and
understand their future.
What is it that you two share?
What makes this friendship so satisfying
for both of you?
Well,
I think we both certainly share a
curiosity about the world and we come
from two different but related worlds.
Uh,
so we had probably spent about 10 hours
of this one hour visit that was
scheduled on July fifth,
1991.
His mother had to talk him into it and
uh,
we weren't halfway.
I mean,
we haven't gotten no place in terms of
our eventual agenda just in that time.
In fact,
the governor of Washington came by and
bills that had to come into the bedroom.
Polar bears we were talking about,
well,
we have fun to start with.
Every relationship should have a lot of
fun and it,
and,
and we've,
we,
we find the world and just such an
interesting place.
So we like to compare notes on it when
we compare notes.
We have a lot of fun doing it.
Part of the time is,
I remember the conversation,
and by the way,
there's a remarkable documentary about
wiring,
which is on Hbo.
Uh,
I think it premieres on Gandy 30th
Monday.
You should take time to take a look at
it,
builds involved in that and you will see
in a sense,
it's called,
I think becoming Warren Buffett.
Yeah,
that's what it's called because it
took me six years,
but think
you're doing well on it so far.
Best is yet to come.
One of the things that happened tonight,
Bill,
was it,
I Guess Your Dad,
uh,
at the dinner said,
you know,
what is it,
what's been the most important quality
for you and you found out that you and
Warren had the same word.
Yeah,
I think curiosity,
which Warren mentioned is a,
an amazing thing where you try and
predict what's going to happen and then
a,
when it doesn't sort of think,
well,
uh,
you know,
that a drug didn't get invented that
stock to go up.
That approach wasn't popular once.
What is it about my model of the world
that's wrong,
you know,
who could I talk to,
what could I read?
And,
and the things that have happened since
1991.
Uh,
mostly good things have been amazing and
just so much fun to talk about.
A
No.
So we read the news and we think,
God,
what did Warren think about that?
You both are readers.
You both,
you read all the time,
all day,
Lauren built.
Oh,
you're a reader.
You also do a lot of sort of courses
online as well.
What does that have done?
What has that done for your life?
The sense of constantly learning.
Well,
go ahead bill.
It's an incredible time to be a learner.
I remember when I was young and I had
the world book,
which is one of Warren's products and it
was very good,
but I always felt like kind of how want
to get into this in more depth.
I understand it better today,
the videos that are online and the
courses that you combined with the very
best professors.
It's phenomenal,
you know,
take a subject like weather or climate
change or what's going on in economics,
what's known,
what's not known now with the
foundation.
A lot of what I need to learn this about
biology,
making vaccines and uh,
what's going on with these,
these various diseases.
This is a phenomenal time to be a
curious person.
The information that's out there,
you know,
I have a,
my,
my biggest problem is that I stay up too
late because I'm reading and then I'm a
little bit tired the next day.
Uh,
the other thing that you share other
than reading his optimism,
you believe in America.
Absolutely.
You have said to me more than once.
Uh,
I would give up a year of my life just
to know what the next 50 is going to be
like.
Yeah.
Even for now.
Why'd you pick for number that came to
me
is just fascinating what's happened just
in my lifetime,
you know,
in the six years.
I shouldn't mention one thing about
reading a,
it was at the library here at Columbia.
I wish I spent probably more time than
any other student I,
I lived there practically.
But I pulled the book out there,
happened to be who's doing an American
that taught me something about my
professor Benjamin Graham.
And then I looked up and I went to the
library and I said,
I want to look more,
learn more about this because I learned
this over here.
That changed my whole life.
You know,
we own Geico now because of a librarian
directing me to some other book and then
following through on that.
It's the chance I,
I read about one fifth,
the pace the bill does,
but I still spend five or six hours a
day reading.
I mean,
it just,
you can learn so much.
I particularly love biography just to,
you know,
to be able to live the lives of.
These people have been
so extraordinary.
The lessons and the,
you know,
the discouragements they face just
everything about it.
So I,
it can't get enough of reading at.
What surprises you most about bill?
Uh,
that's an interesting question.
I guess what really surprised me
initially,
we just found so many things to connect
on that uh,
uh,
he didn't try to sell me a computer.
Uh,
that's probably the only sale he didn't
make all the computer changed my life
for the better in a big way
subsequently.
But uh,
well he,
he,
he just had the same curiosity that,
and the other word,
you have used his focus when the focus
is no question if,
I mean he,
both of us got to where we are in a big,
big way because of focusing.
Bill.
What surprises you about Warren?
I was so
amazed that he comes to investing with
this broad model of the world.
So one of the first questions he asked
me was a,
Microsoft's a small company.
Ibm's this huge company.
Why can you do better?
Why can't they beat you at the software
game that you're playing?
And I always,
you know,
every day I was thinking about,
okay,
what advantage do we have?
What we do.
But nobody ever asked me that question
and we've talked about the economics of
software,
which is a very,
a different and special thing.
And he could relate it to things that
he'd seen and you know,
I didn't understand banking why some get
ahead and some don't.
And so he was able to put that in very
clear terms.
And so I found somebody whose model was
rich enough that it helped me understand
things that I really wanted to know and
we could laugh about things that were a
surprise to us.
I'd say his humility and his sense of
humor really stood out in this
incredible way.
I mean he enjoys what he does and he
shares that with other people.
And even,
you know,
when I ask questions that are pretty
naive that he's probably been asked 15
times,
he's very nice about it took me a long
time to figure this out,
Bill.
But here's how it works.
I tried bill out with some non
transmitted dies and I'd read about them
in scientific American or someplace and
there are only two people in the world
and the history of these dice that
actually figured it out while I was
trying to take their money from them.
And one was the leading symbolic logic
in the world.
And the other was a drunk who didn't
really know any better.
Ask the wrong question.
But bill said,
wait a second.
You choose first and the game was over
you.
You taught him not.
You didn't teach him,
but you brought him into a great
appreciation of bridge.
Yeah,
he can play bridge,
but the family is very big on games as
family with very,
very big on games and,
and uh,
and so we,
we,
we played bridge together and we played
in China going down rivers.
You're supposed to be looking at.
We had a good time point.
Alright,
we've got a lot of questions.
We want to talk to him,
the audience.
Somebody we want to start up in a,
up in the balcony.
So we'll,
we.
So you know,
we haven't forgotten you.
It's hard to see.
But is there a number there that has a
question?
Uh,
okay.
Start it.
Wherever it is.
Yes.
Number six.
I thank both of you guys for being here
today.
My question is in regards to public
health and vaccinations.
Given our current president's publicly
stated stance against the use of
vaccinations both in this country and
abroad,
how would you recommend that we as
students and future leaders in health
sciences best to allocate our resources
to most effectively resist his
alternative fact political philosophy in
regards to the domestic and global
public health?
Thank you.
That's a good place to start.
Well,
the facts about vaccines are very clear
and very strong,
which is both a that they're safe and
that the vaccine schedule has been
designed to reduce disease and you know,
the more parents that adhere to it,
the more not only their children be
protected,
but you have some kids who are immune
deficient and so unless the kids around
them are protected,
then it puts those kids at risk and
there are diseases like measles or
purposes that all it takes is a small
cluster and then mostly those diseases
would be coming in from overseas,
but you can get infection and in some
European countries you've had dads
because the kids weren't vaccinated.
I don't think the US government is going
to come out with any negative
statements.
There may be a commission,
and fortunately if she look at the
facts,
the facts are quite unequivocal.
Uh,
we certainly are speaking out in favor
of vaccines.
So I,
I,
uh,
you know,
I'm a little surprised that we have to
stick up for them,
but it's true in every country that you
get these rumors and particularly in
today's media,
those rumors can get out.
And I had the facts because the rumors
were sort of more salacious or,
uh,
you know,
contrary to what you've been told,
type things,
uh,
here,
I'm sure we'll have a chance if
necessary,
to go through the facts again in and get
a clear positive message from the
government.
And the risk is if vaccines,
some have people are scared of having
vaccines,
the risk is,
well,
there were engaged right now in polio
eradication.
And the only way that succeeds is to get
95 percent of the kids to have these
vaccines.
And there we found,
we ran into a form of anti vaccine
sentiment that's even worse than us.
Rumors and that is that to terrorists
groups.
One in Nigeria,
Boko Haram and another one in Pakistan,
Afghanistan,
the polar bond said that vaccination was
a US plot and you know,
would sterilize women and it was a very
bad thing and they took the women who
are going out to the children's houses
in getting these oral drops,
oral polio vaccine,
and actually killed a number of them.
And so those negative rumors,
the only reason we still have polio
today that were not done is because of
that part of Nigeria that bulk roms
caused armrest in the border areas,
including Baluchistan in Pakistan where
there've been these anti-vaccine
sentiments.
So you know,
our risk is,
is,
is simply those negative things.
So it's not just in rich countries that
we run into this.
It absolutely is causes deaths.
If parents don't know,
bring your kids in and,
and get them fully vaccinated and your
drive to eradicate polio is to show that
you can do it.
Well.
It'll be.
It started in 1988 when it already had
been eradicated in the Americas.
So these were the for the US in the
sixties.
The rest of the Americas in the
seventies showed that it could be done.
And so in 1988,
uh,
well before our foundation was involved,
a rotary and a number of other
organizations said,
let's get rid of this.
And it's been harder than was expected
just because of these sentiments,
you know,
here we are in 2016,
[inaudible] 17 last year,
less than 50 cases.
So we are very,
very close.
In fact,
there are so few cases now,
the way that we track where the virus
is,
is we go and look at sewage samples and
we see because a lot of kids,
uh,
get infected and pass along without
getting paralyzed.
And so it's only through the sewage
samples.
We know that they're still about four
places in Pakistan and Afghanistan and
one place in Nigeria that we,
we haven't gotten there yet.
All right.
Let's see.
Next question.
Uh,
I got to see a car number one.
Thank you both so much for being here.
My question again,
sorry,
is a,
a little bit on the political spectrum.
I was wondering what you're both most
hopeful about in this new political
environment we have.
And also what you're both most worried
about,
you want to take hope are worried more
than.
Well,
I'm,
I'm confident that America will move
ahead.
It's been no from the time I was born
until now.
The real GDP per capita in this country
is one of six for one.
I mean,
nobody ever dreamt that would be
possible.
And when you look at what's happened in
this country over 240 years,
you know,
it's,
it's an absolute miracle.
When I went to Columbia business school,
September 19,
51 woman in the class,
I mean,
this country moves forward and uh,
you can't stop it.
So I'm enormously off.
I say the luckiest person born in the
history of the world was the baby being
born today in this country.
And we will go and,
you know,
everybody,
half the country always is going to be
able to somewhat unhappy close to half
about the last election.
But I grew up in a household,
uh,
in the late 1930 [inaudible].
My Dad was very republican.
Yeah.
My sisters and I didn't get dessert
unless we said something bad about
Roosevelt.
I mean it was just,
it was required and I heard all these
apocalyptic views about after his third
term,
there'll be no more elections.
I've been hearing that all my life and
you know,
year after year after year with
occasional hiccups and,
and an occasional seizure like we had in
2008,
nine,
but this country,
it's all profit folks.
I mean,
you know,
when I came in just think of what it
would have been like in 17,
76,
nothing here and now we've been the
velocity of change and just keep moving.
I mean guys like bill,
you know,
they don't quit,
I mean he,
he moves on to something like polio.
He mentions 50 cases in the world.
There were more than 50
in the ward where I went when I was a
teenager to see a friend of my sisters
and they're all these rocking machines
and everything.
They were destined to a terrible,
terrible life was just one ward in Omaha
and now that's,
you know,
that's the yearly total.
Thanks.
Initially the as well as currently the
rotary in some,
but people kept working on it.
This world moves forward and it's been
doing.
I bought my first stock when I was 11 in
April of 19.
Forty $2.
100.
If you haven't looked at 20,000,
something good must have happened
and it's going to keep happening.
Phil,
I know you share the optimism.
What about concerns?
Well,
their optimism is partly that I think
American innovation is strong support
for research is by and large bipartisan
and so whether it's health breakthroughs
or even energy breakthroughs,
I think you know,
every year that goes by we're going to
have more of those things.
Now.
This administration is new enough.
We don't know how their budget
priorities will come out.
You know,
there are things like foreign aid which
is a small part of the budget,
about 30 billion year,
but that means to us is the biggest that
every time there's new leadership we
have to go in and articulate the
benefits.
It's well spent.
It's not the image that people have in
the past,
and so right now I think there's a lot
of intensity a to make sure we get that
message out and get both in terms of the
executive branch and the Congress to
maintain amazing things like the
president's malaria initiative or
Pepfar,
which is an HIV thing.
These things started under President
Bush.
And so our foundation's had a great
working relationship with democratic and
Republican administrations.
Most people wouldn't realize that US
foreign aid as a percentage of the
economy,
which is generally how it's measured,
reached its low point in 1999,
uh,
under the Clinton administration.
Now,
I'm not saying it was the
administration,
it was a mix of the administration and
the Congress.
Uh,
then,
uh,
during those Bush years,
it went up fairly substantially.
Now the economy helped with that,
but these initiatives were really
amazing and you know,
I'm hopeful that maintaining or even
growing these initiatives will be a
priority when there's a lot of talk
about tax cuts and different spending
activities.
And so it is a bit up in the air,
uh,
during these months ahead.
And you've often made the point that no
matter how big the private contributions
are,
sometimes in terms of tiers,
sheer scale,
you need a government.
Yeah,
somebody asked me today,
you know,
it Pepfar,
which is,
this aids program was canceled when
private philanthropy and make up for it.
Well pepfar's over 5 billion year.
That is this one aid program,
which is a phenomenal thing that's saved
a over 10 million lives that's larger
than our foundation,
which is,
uh,
the largest in the world.
So there's no possibility the government
sector,
US,
UK,
other European donors,
that's $130,000,000,000 here in coal
that's uplifting these poor countries in
health and education.
And if we lose the consensus around
that,
if,
if people draw inward too much,
the we will hurt progress and there will
be millions of lives lost because of it.
One thing that might be mentioned,
Charlie,
who is that
the difference between now and 60 or 70
years ago in the ability of really
bright people,
really innovative,
really energetic people to get financed
to do things is,
is dramatically better than than it was
at that time.
So now if you've got good ideas and
there's good ideas right in those crowd
and you've got energy,
it's far easier to get financing to move
forward.
Those ideas then you couldn't 50 or 60
years.
Is that because of the internet or
crowds crowd sourcing of what is it?
Just lots more capital and people more
optimistic about it.
People are very optimistic on business,
but better ways to connect the tail
capital and absolutely the idea,
it's dramatic.
It's dramatic and willingness to take
risk.
Uh,
you know,
the first venture capital stuff is in
the 19 sixties and it's tiny.
Uh,
Microsoft,
when we were taking outside investment,
we took a,
uh,
at a valuation of $20,000,000,
we took a million dollars for five
percent of the company.
I'll do it retroactive.
And you had your chance,
you had your chance.
We,
we,
we never spent the money.
That is our business was profitable
enough.
We really didn't need to do that,
but we wanted people on our board to
give us advice.
And uh,
there's an episode of Silicon Valley
where all these venture capitalists are
courting this guy.
And that really reminded me a lot.
It was like by that time,
which was 1984,
there were dozens of venture capitalists
and that's something that other
countries have tried to duplicate and
they found a in small part,
but not nearly as well.
This,
this willingness to take risks.
The idea that if you have the failure,
it's not a mark of shame that,
hey,
what's your next startup going to be?
You heard of sacred pumps.
He gets his ideas from Silicon Valley
a card,
let's say where the cards are.
Okay,
number three,
take the cart right there.
So you started this talk about how
you're able to make a model and it won't
accurately predict what happens.
And on the other side of the coin,
I was wondering what happens when you
create such well developed predictive
technology and what are the
ramifications and implications of that
outcome?
Well,
I don't think our predictive,
uh,
you know,
was going to be like an oracle warm
nickname is the oracle of Omaha.
But you know,
the percentage of times you can predict
things like macro economics because they
involve a emotional sentiment.
You know,
we're a long ways away from that.
The biggest modeling thing I'm involved
in as a group that models diseases,
so we look at HIV or tuberculosis and
understand,
okay,
what do we have to do in terms of
diagnosis and drugs to get these things
down.
Once we finished polio will go on and
our next big challenge,
which will take decades,
but I expect we'll be done in my
lifetime is malaria eradication.
So these models aren't nearly at the
point where they can take human
sentiment into consideration,
into the field of economics at a very
basic question about what we should have
done differently before the financial
crisis.
There really is no consensus whether
it's with the public or inside the
professional economists.
They agree that some of the emergency
treatment we did was necessary and
important.
And you know,
I wish I was better understood,
but the,
in terms of the root causes,
it's actually a little disconcerting how
little our models,
our understanding a explain how that
imbalanced got so extreme.
Alright,
where are number two?
I'm in school here at Columbia and I
wanted to ask,
you were talking about that you love
reading.
I wanted to ask you if you have a
particular book that it changed your
life,
like the way you think about things and
I also wanted to ask,
um,
what is the thing that you admire the
most about each other?
Like you build about worrying and the
other way around.
Thank you.
They sort of touched on the,
on the second question,
but go ahead and maybe want to add to it
books though first changed your life.
Well,
a book that changed my life when it was
bio fellow who taught here at Columbia,
Benjamin Graham and I read the book when
I was 19 called the intelligent investor
and I'd,
I'd been interested in investments since
I was maybe seven or eight,
but I'd never.
And I'd read every book in the Public
Public Library.
Why do you think you were interested in
investing when you were seven or eight?
Because I was too dumb to get interested
in.
Poor.
My Dad,
my dad had it
very small investment for and I would
just get on,
I read all the books that he had there,
waiting to go to a luxury or whatever it
might be,
and then I went to the public library
and read them all and it just was a
fascinating subject to me and and but I
didn't have any.
I knew what everybody thought and all of
that at an early age,
but what Graham wrote made sense.
I just happened to pick that book up at
a bookstore in Lincoln,
Nebraska to per se did.
Is there something about your core
competence that made investing in the
perfect place for you to be?
It certainly wouldn't be a pro football
player.
I loved her.
It was a question of zeroing out the
other incompetencies and I was left with
one thing.
No,
I just allocation of capital.
I was actually wired in a way that was
just wouldn't be something I would be
good at.
What so what?
Why I didn't what way high.
I can't tell you precisely,
but I,
I,
I've got the right temperament for it,
which is much more important than Iq.
If you've got more than 120 points of
Iq,
so sell the rest of somebody else.
You don't need it investments,
which,
but you do need the right temperament.
You do it.
You don't have to be able to think for
yourself.
And getting back to the uh,
earlier question,
the first question I asked myself,
when I look at the businesses,
you know,
is it important and easy,
what I can determine about this
business?
And a lot of them don't make it.
Now Bill is looking for hard questions
that plague society and where intellect,
the money may make a difference.
They may not for awhile,
but he's taking on the tough things.
I take my job is to find easy things.
I'm looking for one foot bars to step
over,
you know,
rather than eight foot bar to jump over.
But that's not irrational if you're,
if you're looking at the investment
universe.
But reading is key.
I on the biography,
on the,
on the book thing.
I know I will tell you a wonderful book
to read.
I can tell you a number of intelligent
investor would obviously if you're in
the investment field,
but Katharine Graham's autobiography is
a marvelous book and that's absolutely
honest,
told by an incredible woman who had an
incredible life and then honestly and
someone who you knew very well adjusted
with him and she was a bit reluctant and
had to be assured that she was afraid of
me actually
a book.
But what makes that book so much?
It just,
it is such a broad range of human
experience,
honestly told.
I mean you couldn't have nobody in
Hollywood could write up a,
you know,
a scenario that she lived through and,
and just just see that world develop how
she reacted to it and you can learn so
much.
My partner,
Charlie Margaret just loves Ben
Franklin.
You know,
I mean,
he,
you know,
it.
You can learn from other people and
their mistakes.
And I find a biography.
It was my favorite part of the reason
you love biographies,
Barbie.
Part of the reason you love biographies.
Where is it card?
Uh,
right here,
just come here.
I,
I'm having a hard time seeing the card.
So that right here where the hands are
raised.
Wow.
I'm a senior here at the college.
I'm also a gates millennium scholar.
My family over here.
So I'd like to ask.
So what both of you do and a lot of risk
and sometimes you have to face the fear
of failure without risks.
So I'm asking how did you overcome that
fear and what steps did you take to do
that?
Well,
I think I was very lucky that uh,
when I was in high school,
the computer was brought in there and I
developed a fascination for,
became kind of fanatical about it so
that,
you know,
I didn't view it as risky.
I viewed it as this kind of fun hobby.
Even when I went to college,
which I didn't finish,
but I spent time
in Cambridge,
Massachusetts,
the,
I wasn't sure that would be my life's
work.
Now as the chip came along and made it
mainstream,
it became very obvious that something
dramatic was going to happen.
And so my,
my passion,
my hobby and the area I could start this
company right at the beginning of the
revolution that coincided in a nice way.
And I never felt it was risky.
I,
you know,
if Microsoft had failed,
I didn't have kids or anything,
I could go back to school and uh,
you know,
finished my degree and go get a job
somewhere.
I was very risk averse in,
in running the company.
I always made sure we had enough money
in the bank to pay everybody for at
least a year if nobody paid us at all
because this idea,
I was hiring people who had kids and
families and they were moving to work
there.
And here I was,
you know,
19,
20 years old and sort of telling these
people I'd be paying their salaries.
So I was actually very conservative on a
financial point of view.
And one of the few arguments I have with
Steve Balmer,
who came in and played a phenomenal role
in the success of the company was how
many people could he hire a [inaudible].
I was trying to be so conservative,
but I let him go full speed and uh,
you know,
it turns out our financial success meant
that we never had a conflict about that.
But,
you know,
I think it's great to be risk taking,
uh,
particularly when you're young trying
out different things,
fields that aren't very popular that you
might enjoy,
but I never got into a position where I
was taking a,
actually in any meaningful sense.
I was taking a big risk.
I mean,
the risk of you would not do have acted
because you felt the train was leaving
the station.
Yeah.
And it was so clear,
uh,
that,
you know,
this was going to happen and this was so
much fun.
I mean,
you know,
I was a fanatic.
I didn't believe in weekends.
I didn't believe in vacation.
Uh,
my mom had to negotiate with her.
I'd come once a week for dinner.
Uh,
no matter who the guest was.
That's right.
But Warren,
you have often said you still tap dance
to work adequate.
You can paint with your own colors.
Yeah.
I,
I get,
I'm as excited about tomorrow in terms
of what is going to happen if I wasn't
when I started.
I was having a lot of fun when I
started,
but I'm having just as much fun now and,
and I was.
When I was here at Columbia,
I had terrible fairer.
It was impossible for me to speak in
public.
I mean I wasn't able to do it.
I actually read an ad in the New York
Times.
I went down to midtown,
signed up for a course,
gave the guy a check and then stopped
payment on the check.
I mean it just,
I just petrified.
But finally I actually,
after you get through,
we're here with me today.
Maybe your wish I'd stayed afraid of
public speaking,
but that's another question.
When I got out of the home,
all I finally decided just had to do it.
So I gave a guy $100 in cash and once I
bartered with other dollars in cash,
I jump off the Grand Canyon to get my
money.
So
it changed my life.
But I would say this don't fear failure.
Almost everything that's turned out,
I got turned down by Harvard is the best
thing ever happened among others.
Some good things that happened that
seemed good at the time.
Don't worry about it.
Don't let it eat at you or look back.
Just keep going because you're going to
have some things and forgot them.
Go,
go forward.
I want to go to the back of the room.
I back there
wherever number three is.
Hi,
my name is matthew man.
I'm a first year at Columbia business
school.
Both of you had a moment where you went
out on your own and I guess my question
would be if you were to do it all over
again,
you're in our shoes.
What industry would that be in?
Where would you start your own business
today?
I did the same thing.
Yeah,
but one thing I'd be a failure than
anything else probably.
I mean,
no,
I mean I've had.
I had fun when I was in my twenties,
in my thirties.
Now I made $86,
75,
so I,
I advise students as much as possible.
Look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job.
I mean you don't sleep,
walk through life,
but don't,
don't say it's all going to be great and
I'll do this and I'll do that,
you know,
I'm just marking time to get to be older
that I've told people.
That's like saving up sex for your old
age.
Yeah,
there's not a good idea.
What are you urging them to do?
I'll explain.
Guess what I'm talking about
it just,
yeah,
you really want to be doing what you
love doing and you can't necessarily
find it on your first job.
Right?
But don't give up before you find it.
No.
You've had the unique experience a
because of your curiosity be because of
your involvement in,
in global health.
Just see the impact of a lot of other
areas,
uh,
whether it's biomedicine
or whether it's,
you know,
a whole range of other things other than
computer science.
If you were going to drop out of Harvard
today,
which field would you be most likely
attracted to?
Well,
I love the hard sciences and there's
some phenomenal things that people will
get a chance to be part of a,
I'd still probably pick computer science
because the work in artificial
intelligence today is that a really
profound level,
uh,
in,
our ability not just to play games,
but that is a profound milestone.
The alphago work that the deep mine
people at Google were able to achieve
and that kind of technologies and all
the leading companies and a lot of the
universities with Ai,
creation of agents,
the ability to read and understand
material,
it is going to be phenomenal.
So anything connected with that I think
would be an exciting lifetime career.
I also think in energy we have the
imperative to have energy that's
reliable,
cheap and clean and no system available
today can provide that,
whether it's for rich countries or four
per poor countries.
And so the innovations there will be
profound and there's many paths that
could provide that solution.
Finally,
I think biology,
it's the most thrilling time,
you know,
we are going to figure out a obesity
cancer,
her,
even things that are very hard like
depression because the,
you know,
the mind is,
is,
is even more complicated than other
parts of the body.
I see this through the lens of the
diseases of the poor,
of the infectious disease where new
vaccines,
new drugs,
we are moving faster than ever.
And some of these are platform
technologies like DNA vaccines that are
going to give us,
just that one thing will give us lots
and lots of solutions.
And so working in that space,
uh,
is,
is phenomenal.
Now I say this to my children,
uh,
and you know,
they,
they may not want to do hard sciences.
The one who's picked wants to counsel
patients and,
and be a doctor and even more than the
science piece,
that relationship with patients is what
grabs her.
So everybody has their own taste.
But in terms of big impact,
those three higher science problems
would be at the top for me.
Alright,
next,
right here,
right next to number one.
Hello?
Uh,
thank you guys for being here.
Also,
thank you to Mr Gates.
I am also a gates scholar and without
your foundation I'm going to be here.
Uh,
many industrial based communities have
been severely affected with higher
levels of unemployment due to the
increasing utilization of automation
which ends up displacing workers.
What do you mean?
What do you believe is a possible
solution to unemployment arising from
automation?
It's a good question because there's a
lot of about globalization and all of
that and a lot of other people step
forward and,
and talk about how technology and the
impact technology is having on jobs and,
and the demand for new kinds of skills.
Yeah.
And we were here in 1800 and conducting
this
and somebody would point out that
eventually tractors would come along
and,
and better fertilizer and had that 80
percent of the people are now employed
on the farm and in a couple of hundred
years it's going to be two or three
percent.
And what are we going to do with all
these people?
Well,
the answer is we release them.
We Keynes wrote something about it and
something called essays on persuasion
and he wrote a 1930 about what a more
prosperous society would become,
like any actually postulated that,
uh,
in 100 years and we're now 87 years old
from the,
that there would be four to eight times
as much output per capita and he's
remarkable,
but he didn't quite get out my get
distributed.
But the idea more output per capita,
which is what the progress is made on
productivity,
that,
that should be harmful,
decide is,
is crazy.
I mean the distribution may be a
problem,
but if one person could push a button
and turn out everything we turned out
now is that good for the world,
are bad for the world.
You know,
you'd have to figure out how to
distribute it.
But,
but you'd free up all kinds of
possibilities for everything else.
So you,
every,
everything should be devoted initially
to getting greater productivity.
But people who fall by the wayside
through no fault of their own,
as the goose lays,
golden eggs should still get a chance to
participate in that prosper me.
And that's where government comes in,
right?
Building to add to that.
Yeah,
the problem of excess is a different
problem than a problem shortage.
You know,
if all the tractors,
computer stopped working,
then we would have problems of shortage
there.
Uh,
and you know,
we just wouldn't have enough people to,
to make the output a problem of excess
really forced us to look at the
individuals affected and take those
extra resources and make sure that
they're directed to them in terms of
reeducation and incomes policies and the
need for labor in terms of smaller class
size,
helping handicap kids,
reaching out to the elderly.
The demand for Labor is not at zero.
If you ever get to that point,
fine,
you can shorten the work week and uh,
you'll,
you'll be just fine with that.
And so the,
this idea of taking an individual who
during their generation is affected,
I think there's a lot to be learned
about that.
A lot of thinking we have to do,
but the macro picture that it enables,
uh,
is,
is an opportunity number two.
Also,
I'm urging people at the back.
So you have a chance and we want to go
back up to the balcony as well.
Uh,
so when I see number six,
welcome to six after two.
Yes.
Hi,
my name is Sam.
I go to Columbia College and my question
is,
what steps did you think needs to be
taken in order to improve public
education,
particularly in a economically depressed
areas of the United States?
Yeah,
yeah.
I think this is a super important issue
because the uh,
dropout rates,
although they've gone down a little bit,
they're still very high end and very
based on income and even kids who
graduate,
a lot of them don't enter college or
they do enter college and they end up in
these remedial courses for their reading
or math capabilities.
And those people have an extremely high
dropout rate from higher education and,
and they can incur debt.
They have a negative experience.
So we have a long ways to go in
education.
There are some very strong points of
light,
like here in New York City,
some of the charter schools are with
even less resources.
Then schools that large doing a
phenomenal job of educating kids.
There are a lot of countries,
particularly in Asia who spending way
less of their GDP on education,
are doing a great job educating their
kids and it's not just the top 20
percent,
they're bottom 20 percent is pretty
phenomenal in the case of China,
South Korea and Singapore.
And so looking at what we've learned in
charter schools in terms of building the
culture,
giving teachers feedback,
uh,
what is good teaching look like?
Do we give teachers a chance to learn
from each other about that interactive
element that makes the subject seem
relevant and important?
There are
great teachers,
but spreading those practices is,
has been very,
very tough.
And so I'd say it's a,
a top priority and we've taken our
foundation has that for our work in the
United States.
Education is,
is the top priority.
Whereas outside the US,
uh,
we,
we take on health.
It's a tough problem because the
institution of education are fairly
resistant to change and people are,
are not yet convinced by various
approaches very easily.
Uh,
but we need to keep at it.
We're going to,
you know,
stay in actually putting in more money
into trying to help help models.
Okay.
I'm up number six.
Hey,
first they weren't the time.
Well,
I witnessed the role of your foundation
and eliminating polio in India and I'm
really thankful for that.
Uh,
my,
my question is more on how to set the
basic level of debate in any,
any public sense.
Like there are many trade of how to
explain climate change policy for people
who are losing,
losing jobs in the coal sector.
How do you balance the current current
short term economic goals with the
longterm
peaceful transition to renewable sources
of energy?
No,
it's a good question.
The certain topics are so complicated
like climate change,
that to really get a broad understanding
is a bit difficult.
I'm particularly when people take any of
that complexity and trying and create
uncertainty about it.
Uh,
and in,
uh,
for example,
India's kind of paradigmatic in that
they want to electrify for all sorts of
good reasons having to do with health
and reading at night and a quality of
life.
And the question of should they delay
electrification,
uh,
for climate issues is going to be very
difficult.
The ideal is to innovate in such a way
that they can go full speed ahead on
electrification without emitting the two
that a,
the natural path of them today,
which is coal is the way to go.
And so we have a lot of cost reduction
to do because rich countries may be able
to buy premium electricity when you get
to middle income or lower,
that's just not going to happen.
And you know,
democracy has this allocate these
resources in terms of investing in the
future and things like research and
investing in,
in the present.
And when you have a problem like the
financial crisis,
then you do get a little bit of more of
short term thinking.
And I'm hopeful.
I think it's better for the world and
for the country if we can get back into
a little bit more of a focus on the
longterm.
We have some question from facebook.
Warren central tenant of your investing
is to invest for the long term.
And this comes from Brian White who says
how my bill and weren't convinced
investors to think beyond short term
returns,
to encourage world changing innovation.
Well,
I've spent my life trying to convince
people on the testing for the longterm
and listen to vinyl,
how to double my money tomorrow.
I'd probably have most with the short
term,
it's much.
It's much easier to invest for the long
term if you're just talking pure
investment because you know what's going
on in my view,
be very high.
Probably what's going to happen 10,
20 years from now in a major way.
And I don't have the faintest idea
what's gonna happen tomorrow or next
week.
But you wouldn't get if you're talking
about societal,
uh,
it,
it's,
it's very tough because politicians,
they selections either every two years
or six years.
And the way the way a particular
integrational districts have been
organized,
primaries have become more and more
important.
And so it's very hard to have a
politicians think of something as
wonderful for the country for 20 years,
but will cost
them the election two years from now.
And that,
that's a basic problem in a democracy
and it gets to be more of a problem as,
as we get arraigned,
we've arranged congressional districts,
so the primary dominates because a very
limited number of people turned out in
their motive,
tend to be on the extremes of both
parties.
So it,
uh,
it's not easy whether you're going to
make an investment in a company or
whether you're going to buy the company.
What are the factors that you have to be
that you're looking for?
Which test?
I'm looking for durable,
competitive advantage.
I'm looking for something that has a
moat around it for a considerable period
of time and I'm looking for and I'm
honest,
enabled management to run it because I
don't know how to run it myself.
And I'm looking for a purchase price
that's not excessive,
but it's better to pay a little too much
for something that's a very good
business a than it is to buy some
bargain,
a but really the company,
but not much of a future.
And I don't know,
I don't have a ability to predict with a
high probability of success the future
of most companies,
so I'm looking for the exception.
But the nice thing is if there's
thousands of companies out there,
I really don't have to be right on a
couple of.
I mean it's exactly the opposite of,
of baseball where you have called
strikes and the pitcher is trying to
throw it to it.
The worst part of the strike zone for
you.
And if he succeeds in getting into that
corner three times and you don't swing,
you're out in investing.
It's a no,
it's an old called strike things.
I can sit there all day and somebody
confirming one company after another.
And finally I got one of my sweet spot.
Both of you have chosen both wives and
partners.
Well,
I'm Charlie monger added what?
Charlie Munger changed my views.
He'd be flying them in a huge way in
terms of looking for the quality
companies and,
and,
and looking for the ability to make an
investment that would work out well for
five or 10 or 20 years as opposed to
something that might.
There might be one I called it a cigar,
but investing,
whether it was one puff left in the
cigar,
the cigar was free.
So he picked up these disgusting looking
things and got one puff out of them,
went onto another one and that worked
okay.
But it was small scale and it really
doesn't build something satisfying.
So,
so he,
he kept forcing me in the direction of
saying,
you know,
is this really a business we want to own
for forever?
And,
and,
uh,
do we want to get.
So it's like a marriage.
I mean,
do you want to get associated with this
person forever?
And it's a great way to look at things.
A bill,
uh,
your wife,
Melinda has added what?
Well,
she's four children,
three children.
How much time do I have?
She is your partner and she was there in
the philanthropy from day one at
Microsoft.
I had two partners for Mason.
I had Paul Allen really early days and
then Steve bombers when
it got bigger and we would not have
achieved anything what we without those
partnerships,
because you know,
when things are tough,
when you're making big decisions,
having somebody who's really in there
with you committed a for me.
I couldn't have done without that,
for the foundation.
Melinda's an amazing partner.
She thinks about the people issues
better than I do.
She knows when I get over excited about
the science,
she can,
uh,
you know,
make sure we're,
we're being realistic about it and it
makes it fun.
You know,
last week,
uh,
I went to Europe to world economic form.
She went to Nigeria and then this
weekend we just sat and talked about,
okay,
what did we see,
what does that say about the work we
should do a.
and so,
you know,
I don't think I'd enjoy it without a
partner in particularly someone amazing
like her.
It's more fun with a partner.
I'm in Charlotte and I've had more fun
working together that neither one of us
would have had individually and we have
never had an argument after
being together for 58.
You could talk every day.
Not Anymore.
We know what the other guy's going to
say.
We just got,
we talked it all out 15 years ago.
So if you see trolley and he says,
why haven't you called?
And you'd say,
well,
I knew what you say anyway.
No,
there's no question about it.
What am.
I shall have a lot of fun together.
Alright,
right there.
Let's say number two.
Hi.
Hi,
my name is molly is anger.
I'm a student at Barnard College.
Um,
I guess what I'm basically wondering is
what your main considerations are when
you're choosing where to donate and what
causes to donate to and what the main
challenges are that are associated with
that.
Yeah,
I wholesale it because I made a choice
that I wanted to have a.
well originally my first wife and I
planned that I would pile up and she
went on pile it.
But uh,
and then,
uh,
that was plan number one.
But she,
she died,
uh,
in,
in 2004,
and then I had the problem of figuring
out the best way to distribute what
turned out to be a lot of money and I
wanted,
I wanted some people who had similar
values and similar objectives and what I
have,
but I also want to,
people would pour in intelligence and
energy in case of bill and Melinda,
a lot of their own funds,
we'll work out a full time,
but who really saw society as I sought,
which was at every life is of equal
value in and that if you start with that
and then you figure what your might be
good at changing whether it's medicine
or education or early learning or
whatever it may be.
A,
you know,
that was my answer was that the
wholesale and retail philanthropy would
drive me crazy.
But wholesale,
we are really like
bill.
Yeah.
For our work at the foundation,
the belief in innovation,
which,
uh,
both Melinda and I sought Microsoft.
Our question was,
okay,
how do we bring that kind innovation to
help the world's poorest in.
We learned that coming up with new
vaccines that although you can pay a lot
to have them created,
the marginal cost comes down to less
than a dollar,
so great getting a new vaccine for the
main cause of diarrhea or our pneumonia,
uh,
that can be a phenomenal thing.
So you're looking for these super
nonlinear dramatic things because as you
know,
per poor person are compared to
government funding,
philanthropy is actually quite small and
yet the funding vaccine projects,
the government isn't as good as that as
a philanthropist who assembles a team.
And over time it's learning how to do
that very well.
And we had models in a Rockefeller
Foundation was a phenomenal foundation.
The green revolution is just one of many
things that they did,
which raised agricultural productivity
and saved,
avoided hundreds of millions,
a starving.
And so studying the other foundations
that have taken these big breakthroughs,
uh,
and created model out of those that was
very informative to the,
to what we've gone after.
What's the most important lesson you've
learned though,
about making investments from the
foundation today that you learned along
the way?
Well,
I think,
uh,
when we started out,
I thought that just coming up with the
new vaccine or drug alone would be
enough and that the world would then
take that and get it out to all the
children of the world.
Uh,
you know,
partly through field this,
I did that Melinda did,
looking at the statistics,
that delivery system,
it doesn't get out to a lot of the kids.
And so having to figure out how people
are hired or how that was funded and
measure this,
what's called primary health care,
uh,
we were drawn into that out of
necessity.
It didn't fit the normal sort of in the
lab,
you know,
come up with this great concoction and
uh,
and yet in order to achieve our goals,
we needed to,
to think about those delivery pieces.
In fact,
sometimes the state of the product
actually had to be simpler in some ways
in order to get through that very
limited delivery capacity.
And now we're getting to 86 percent of
the world's children with vaccines.
It was,
uh,
about 70 percent when we got started.
So that's good increase.
We still have have 14 percent to go,
one that have amazing a convening and
persuasive powers as well.
So I mean they,
they bring something far more to it than
just money.
I mean they,
they work incredibly hard and do my
three children in their foundations,
but they work incredibly hard at getting
governments involved in vaccines or
whatever it may take.
And that,
uh,
that just as you know,
it's an extra dimension that I think
very few people have in the field.
It's a hands on travel to Melinda is in
Africa and she's holding a little baby.
I mean she is actually thinking,
you know,
this good needs to be vaccinated,
has a decent chance in education,
all that.
I feel the same way about the kid,
but what I really think is going to have
a pee on me and on head was going,
I had.
So you know,
there's just a difference in that human
touch that makes a big difference.
I'm halfway in between.
I think he's closer to me number three
and number four,
first one,
then three,
then four
small me at the Columbia business
school.
If the current government were to ask
for your advice on immigration or
healthcare reform,
what would you recommend to them?
Lauren?
Well,
on him,
on immigration.
Well,
immigration.
I mean this country is built on it.
I always say to people through
immigration,
let's put it in retroactively.
Everybody leaves
this country and you think about it.
Overdose before from me,
but we're sitting here in part because
of two.
George immigrants who in 1939 and August
signed the most important letter perhaps
in the history of the United States and
you can.
You can go to the Internet and go to
search thing and
yeah,
and just type in Einstein.
Roosevelt 1939.
Leo's Alard and Albert Einstein to
immigrants came here.
They both.
They came directly from Germany,
large came from Hungary before that and
they told President Roosevelt that the
Germans were likely to develop an atom
bomb which was likely to work.
It's less than a full page and we'd
better get to work on something fast and
that the Manhattan project came out of
that and it hadn't been for those two
immigrants.
Who knows whether we'd be sitting in
this room,
immigration,
I'm gonna,
let him handle,
can do Andy Grove.
You'd go up and down,
right?
It's,
this country has been built on the west.
Exactly why?
By immigrants and you can take them from
any country.
Pretty good one.
And then they'd come here and they've
found something that unleash the
potential that the place where they left
did not have,
were the product of it.
Let me,
the question also is about healthcare.
I mean,
what can you tell us about healthcare
that you think is important in terms of
the consideration of what might happen?
I mean,
if you were building a healthcare plan
for America,
what would be the elements that you
would want to
include?
Well,
there's no doubt that in order to
provide decent healthcare,
the percentage of GDP devoted to it is
going to go up over time.
It's already very high and yes,
there's some efficiencies to be gained,
uh,
in that,
you know,
18 percent are so number.
But as society ages,
as we come up with new things like joint
replacement,
organ transplant,
which are going to create lots of human
benefits,
we're going to have to have more
resources overall,
including more government resources for
healthcare.
And so it's a tough problem because you
have both access problems today and you
have costs problems today.
And you know,
whenever I look at a problem,
I have this one simple lens which has
those innovation should help here,
but in this case,
innovation,
while it will provide breakthrough drugs
that will save costs,
like if you can cure Alzheimer's,
which we certainly haven't done yet,
that will save on huge longterm care
costs.
So we have these chronic diseases that
we've made less progress on,
uh,
than,
than some of the others.
And you know,
the market mechanism to get Pharma to go
after those things.
And the basic research,
those funds,
I am quite optimistic that we'll have
some advances,
but they'll also give us some very
expensive things that will mean we're,
we're spending more money against it.
And I do hope you know that at some
point that we really are calling on the
best minds to look at the incentives for
the breakthroughs,
the most efficient system we have here.
I think there's a lot of unhappiness in
the country now.
A stems from the fact that the
healthcare system isn't delivering.
And yet,
uh,
you know,
people are saying less government,
more government,
uh,
you know,
I don't think they're being given the
depth of education about why it's so
tough that over time will help them a
vote for the rest of the depth of
explanation.
Let me go,
I'll go to facebook and just a moment,
but where was I promised three,
four to six.
A three is there and six is up there.
So go three,
six and we'll go to facebook.
Hi,
my name is Josh Schaffer and I'm a
dental resident at Columbia.
My question is for future doctors and
dentists of America.
What,
what advice do you have in giving about
having a proper balance of providing
that health care,
but also mastering the concepts of
business and economics?
Well,
it told Gawande is incredible.
Author.
He,
in the current issue of the New Yorker
has a,
uh,
the latest in a wonderful articles about
the healthcare system and he's talking
about the people who do sort of heroic
surgery,
like are paid twice as much as the
people who are on an ongoing basis and a
great incremental way learning about the
patient and seeing what works for them.
And He,
it's a calling to say,
hey though,
that part of the system needs to be run
better,
needs,
needs more resources.
Uh,
and,
you know,
so I think it's brilliant that he's
saying that.
And it also corresponds to what,
uh,
what is working in some other countries.
A six.
Hello,
my name is Columbia College.
So you both have invested a great deal
of money abroad,
but there is a prevailing belief by some
that there are pressing issues in
America.
There are poor people here,
there are sick people here and we should
deal with that first before even
tackling anything abroad.
So what are your thoughts on that?
My own personal thought is that every
life is of equal value and uh,
in many ways,
many ways,
if you have a limited number of dollars,
you actually can do more for more people
outside the United States.
We do have greater resources here for
our 320 million people that exists
around the world for seven plus billion
people.
So if,
if you,
you can improve the lot of more people
by intelligently spending a billion
dollars or any other number,
uh,
in other areas of the world actually
then here.
And I know coming from Omaha and having
the money,
I have people say,
well,
why not spend it all in?
You know,
you grow up hearing,
almost done all kinds of things for you.
And I absolutely acknowledge that.
But in the end,
if I've got x dollars to spend,
I can make life better for more people
if I can have it intelligently allocated
in other parts of the world actually
than the United States.
And that draws a fair amount of
criticism.
But I live with because I just.
What I believe
all lives have equal value is really the
driving force behind my foundation.
I'm an accident.
I won the ovarian lottery when I was
born in the United States in 1930.
He was 40 to one against me.
I was male that now it's 80 to one
against being a male in the United
States in 1930.
I was just plain lucky my life had been
partnered with.
Bill always said if I had been born a
long time ago,
I'd have been some animals lunch because
I can't run fast and I can't climb trees
and everything.
And I'd be saying I allocate capital
and wouldn't work.
And I was lucky but 79 out of the 80
weren't as lucky as I was at that time.
Bill,
go ahead bill.
Is it
the helping people in other countries?
The foreign aid budget of the US is,
is point eight percent of the budget and
there will be in,
in the years ahead and discussion about
is that we're doing it saves lives for
typically about a thousand dollars of
life saved and in terms of stability and
countries,
uh,
eventually being self sufficient and be
part of the world economy.
There are some,
some huge benefits to that.
So if we were talking about should we
spend 20 or 30 percent overseas?
Okay.
You know,
that would be a very interesting
discussion.
But what we're trying to preserve a is
something that's gotten smarter and
smarter all the time,
has proven benefits,
all of which are things that our
foundation core invests,
invests in the same things like,
like the polio thing is,
is point eight percent.
So I'm hopeful that in a big world that
can remain a priority.
Or.
Let me go to another facebook question.
This is from uh,
uh,
Nadia says,
how might bill and Warren encouraged
innovation,
particularly among teens and young
adults?
How do you encourage innovation?
Well,
I think you have a market system
provides rewards for it yet and we
haven't,
I mean we,
we have an incubator for innovation in
the United States and you know,
broken of school.
Andy Grove can come from Hungary and I
mean it just welcomes it and thank God,
I mean that's why we have the kind of
prosperity that we have.
I mean the question of how it gets
divided as a secondary question and that
is not good solid as well by the market
system,
but our system is just designed for it
and look at what is happening.
Number one.
Also,
I want to make sure we get the people
that back so we would only have five
minutes left so there's a couple of
hands up in the back so please recognize
it.
Hi,
my name is Scott here.
I'm a senior and the junior school as
men have such great influence.
Uh,
I'm curious,
and we touched a little bit about this,
the last question,
but how you deal with reconciling your
convictions with maybe what is believed
by the public,
maybe even a majority considering that
you have the wealth and power and fame
to make such great things happen
either.
Well,
I don't see,
you know,
the,
the convictions I have a,
you know,
I love sharing them and talking to
people and understanding where people
disagree.
Uh,
you know,
I can be overly science centric about
things.
I,
uh,
you know,
there's all sorts of clauses that are
super important that our foundation,
because we have limited resources,
we don't get to go and do.
There's,
there's lots of diseases.
Uh,
there's aspects of education in a part
of the strength of philanthropy is its
diversity and,
and,
and so just by sharing the fact that
it's fun,
it really can have measurable impact.
I hope that sets an example for all of
philanthropy.
I don't happen to believe that,
you know,
my voice should be that much louder than
other people.
Uh,
you know,
and so,
some of these big political donations,
you know,
at least,
uh,
you know,
I and worn as well,
we've chosen not to have that be a huge
way that we're spending our money.
That's a personal choice.
Uh,
you know,
the money's being saved for,
not for the megaphone,
but for the work of the foundation.
We got a podium over certain short,
but people do not
with a partner like Charlie monger,
you don't have to worry about my views
being accepted,
automatically point out the shortcomings
of the,
the influence of money in politics.
I agree.
The thing is,
is bad news for this country,
I think citizens united was a terrible
decision and the idea that somebody can
pour millions and millions of dollars
into a campaign and in certain cases and
not even be identified,
I think really kind of
goes counter to kind of America,
I believe in the two of you created
along with blend and others created the
giving pledge.
How's that going?
Going?
Terrific.
Go conducted.
It really is going to.
Philanthropy is kind of where it is.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is,
um,
you know,
we love philanthropy of all types and
part of the strength American clamp is
actually people with very little who are
incredibly generous here though we said,
for the people who are,
are super lucky to have over a billion
dollars,
we want a group who are working together
who are committed to give the majority
of their wealth away to learn from each
other.
What's worked,
what hasn't worked,
how do you involve your kids?
Uh,
how do you hire staff?
And they'll find areas that are working
on together and cooperate,
but we're not pulling any money.
And we thought we'd get 20,
25 people together.
And in fact,
now we're at 156.
So it is a wonderful yearly eventide
made some great people.
I do think that the quantity and quality
has gone up because we're getting
together.
We'll never be able to measure that in a
direct way in a,
we're making special efforts in China
and India because now we have a lot of
welfare and that wasn't there before.
And uh,
in their own way,
I think they,
by having a strong philanthropic sector
that will help those countries and
therefore help the world was
interesting.
Now build an I are having dinner
actually with the group tonight for
example,
but
you go back 100 or a hundred 50 years,
people got wealthy by making some money
from the oil refinery are still a mill
and building another one and every Ford
with Volvo plant them build cars and
then they,
it would be from actually from retained
earnings which eventually turned into
cash.
Now you can get rich very young just by
having an idea and you can get that idea
monetize and capitalize in a way that
you cannot believe.
So we are particularly interested in
getting younger people interested in
philanthropy because there will be huge.
There are huge fortunes by people that
are now in their twenties and thirties.
And just think of what those potential
for that group.
And so this thing has worked out way,
way better,
including getting younger people to join
us.
Number six.
Hello,
my name is Christina Nunez.
I'm a fellow dental student to Josh.
Thank you for speaking with us today.
Um,
I'm curious about your insight related
to relationships.
I'm personally given a desire to honor
myself and respect other individuals
have found it difficult throughout life
to discern which relationships to really
foster and invest in and accept
challenges from and which to kind of
forgo and abandoned because there are
more harmful than helpful.
Um,
so are there any major life lessons that
you two have learned through your
personal experiences?
Well,
that's a very important question and the
more you will move in the direction of
the people that you associate with site,
it's important to associate with people
that are better than yourself.
And actually the most important decision
met.
Ado Bank.
Not all of you will be the spouse you
choose.
Okay.
And,
uh,
you really,
you want to associate with people who
are the kind of person you'd like to be.
You'll,
you'll move in that direction.
And the most important person by far in
that respect is you respond to that.
I can't over emphasize how important
that is.
You're right that the friends you have
a,
they will form you as you go through
life and uh,
uh,
makes good friends,
keep them for the rest of your life
would have them be people that you
admire as well as why come,
they'll do that to that.
Yeah.
Some friends do bring out the best in
you,
uh,
and,
and so those,
it's good to invest in those
friendships.
Uh,
and you know,
some friends challenge you about things
you're doing,
uh,
and that,
you know,
that level of intimacy is great.
I wouldn't say that,
um,
you know,
I was so obsessed with work.
I didn't invest.
I'd say in my twenties and thirties as
much as I should have.
It's really through Melinda and seen
know other people.
I realized,
okay,
that is really worth the investment,
to have those people as a,
you're always there to help them and
vice versa.